If for some reason you need to replace
a needle. The process is the same for both
the main bed and the ribber.
First remove the carriage from the bed,
Push the sponge bar out as far as
need to, to release the damaged needle.
Just an FYI, the sponge bar is also called a needle retaining bar.
That makes sense, no?
And this is a good time to check
the condition of your sponge bar.
Lift up on the butt of the needle
and lift it out of the slot.
Pull the needle out
of the slot and toss it.
Replace it with a new needle in reverse.
Hold the needle by the butt,
insert the hook into the slot until it clears at the back and then
drop it into place.
Then replaced the sponge bar
back into position.
If that sponge bar is flat,
get one ordered and get it replaced.
One trick that many knitters use is
to borrow needles from the ends
of the needle bet as a temporary
replacement until you
can order more needles.